unos paisajes espectaculares pero un
gran desafío para estos ciclo
montañistas en las montañas de Grecia
109 corredores de 21 nacionalidades como
Estefan pedalearon en la primera edición
de la helenique
es la carrera más dura que hice en mi
vida he hecho varias carreras así pero
esta Está muy difícil las subidas son
duras las bajadas también son dudas
938 kilómetros
29.000 metros de desnivel una de las
carreras de ciclo montañismo más dura
del mundo
de los 109 participantes solo 35
llegaron a la meta la mayoría como René
no pudo culminarla
[Música]
día más duro de mi vida creo que estuve
Más allá de mis límites
este tipo de competencias se han
multiplicado los últimos años antes de
lanzar este año la helenique Nelson
y en Marruecos
para mí era corredores en lugares como
este es épico y vienen por eso buscan
este reto quieren ponerse a prueba y
probar sus límites ver hasta dónde
pueden ir y eso es lo que les da
satisfacción
una satisfacción que logró Adrián yesti
después de cuatro días 12 horas y seis
minutos el corredor suizo fue El
vencedor de esta primera edición
no me doy cuenta de lo que pasó estoy
muy cansado tengo frío realmente no me
doy cuenta de lo que pasó
a pesar de las dificultades la mayoría
de los corredores fueron entusiasmados y
tienen previsto participar en la próxima
competencia que se realizará en agosto
en bicistán con un recorrido de 1880
kilómetros